- Okay, Victoria, right?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Victoria, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I was born in the ocean.
- What do you mean?
- My mom had me in the ocean.
- You were on a boat?
- [Victoria] No, in the
ocean, she was swimming.
- [Mark] Oh geez, and you
were born in the water?
- Yeah, she had me in the
ocean like a real live mermaid.
- Here in Los Angeles?
- Yes.
- Wow.
- I'm born and raised
here in Cali, all natural Cali girl.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
You grew up with both your parents?
- No, I only have one parent, my mother.
That's the only one I know,
that's the only one I have.
My father left when I was four months.
All I know about my father
is that he's an ex Navy SEAL,
that he looks like a black Elvis Presley,
he's 6'7", and he's got nine sisters.
- [Mark] Okay.
- And that's about the only thing I know.
I don't even know his name.
I grew up very hard, actually.
I'm the oldest out of six.
I got four younger brothers
and a younger sister.
They were very sheltered
and covered, I was not.
I'm like the black
sheep, I learned and know
more than they know,
especially about our mother.
My mother was a topless
dancer for 16 1/2 years,
so I grew up in the
field of entertainment.
I was molested when I was
four by my brother's dad.
I've always been the brave type, though.
I've always been the
protector of my family,
I guess you could say the backbone.
I grew up with my mother
and my grandparents, and...
Sometimes I talk with my hands
because that's my first language.
I can sing in sign language.
I feel that I've
lived
a life that wasn't mine.
I grew up very fast for
my age, very very fast,
and to me I feel like I've
done almost everything
in the world except for
taking life and giving life.
I have no children of my own.
I adopted my little
brother when I came back.
The state of California
took me away from my mother
'cause they said that
she was an unfit mother,
which was not true, she
was a very fit mother.
She just had problems like
everybody else, you know?
One of her problems was
that she was an alcoholic,
and she claimed it to the fullest.
She was not ashamed of
it, was very proud of it,
and that's one thing I can
say I have from my mother.
I'm very proud of myself,
and I'm glad she told me
before she passed, it'll
be a year this January 6th
that she's been gone, she's been dead.
She told me that she was very proud of me,
and that never changed.
If I'm gonna change, change
for myself and no one else,
and stay the person that
I am, stay who I am,
stay who I am, stay who I am.
I grew up off and on with my mother
and from foster home to foster home,
group home to group home.
My brothers and sisters had their fathers,
so they were allowed to
go home to their fathers.
I was the only one that
was left in the system,
so I grew up in the system.
They called me a chronic runaway,
'cause I ran from every
home, every group home,
every house, every foster home,
every group home that
they put me in, I left.
I took off, ran home, always went home.
I'd leave on the weekends
so that way I could spend
the weekend with my mom and knew
that I was gonna be caught
by Monday or something, so.
- [Mark] So you're
running away to go home?
- Yes, I ran away to go home, yes.
I'd run away to go home.
You could put me anywhere in this world,
I'd still know my way home.
Always went home.
But I'm a survivor, you know?
We have been in our family.
My mom grew up from a very wealthy family,
but she's the type where she
didn't depend on my family
for money, we make our
own, we get our own,
you get your own, you make your own,
'cause it's better to have your own.
It's not good to always depend
on your family, you know?
'Cause family's not always
there when they need to be.
I'm a very big family person.
I'm big on traditions
and traditional things
like having to do with
housing, traditionally raised.
I grew up on both sides of the
fence as far as good and bad.
Half my family are Jehovah's Witnesses,
the other half practiced magic.
I'm not religious, I'm
spiritual. I'm very spiritual.
I believe that everything
that happens in life
happens for a reason
and it's a part of the
journey and a reason
that we're all here for.
We don't know what we're
here for, but we're here
for a reason, maybe to change
the world or improve the world
or have the world or, you know, something.
I'm a happy go lucky person.
I see the good in everybody
no matter if they're evil and bad,
I still see the good in
them someway, somehow.
I'm weird. (laughs)
I'm not submissive. I don't
like submitting to nobody.
My mommy say, if the little
bitch don't listen to me,
she won't listen to anybody
at all, and that's true.
I don't like listening to nobody.
I always wanted to go to the
army or the Navy or the Marines
but my mom said it wouldn't be good for me
because I'll be discharged
because I talk back,
and you're not allowed to do that.
I got a mouth on me.
My mom always say, I got a
mouth like a sailor's wife,
'cause I'll cut you out
in a heartbeat. (laughs)
But I grew up...
I grew up learning in ways that I feel
that maybe I shouldn't have,
but then I should have learned, in a way.
Me personally, I'd rather
live to make the world
a better place than to
make it a horrible place.
I'm really into kids, I love
kids, I love teaching kids.
Okay, I started getting high, right?
So my mom had got real
sick and ended up going
to the hospital, and it
was just me and the baby
inside this hotel
where it wasn't frightening
but it was just disturbing, you know?
Me, I'm not scared, I'm
not scared of anything.
I don't fear anything.
I look fear in the face and I tell him,
I face my fear, I fuck my fear,
I fight my fear, I defeat my fear.
That's how I look at it.
I look death and fear
in the face every day
and tell them, fuck you, suck my clit.
Sorry for my words, but that's how I live,
that's how I look at it.
I don't care what happens,
anything that happens.
Don't do nothing to my family or to...
I don't care what you do to me,
just don't hurt the ones I love.
'Cause if you hurt the ones that I love,
then you're gonna get fucked over.
Just remember the
consequences and repercussions
of fucking around with me, you know?
I may not be all that, I may not be
all big and high and
mighty, but I'm 100% myself
and I've got god on my side always.
- [Mark] What is your drug
out here on the street?
- I smoke crack and Kush.
Yep, I stay "C.C.
Rider", calm and careful.
- [Mark] And what do you do for money?
- Mm, a little bit of everything,
a little bit of everything.
I'm a jack of all trades. I hustle.
I hustle, I hustle very well.
I have a couple of hustles.
I serve, I trick a bit.
My original thing before I was in prison,
I was an adult entertainer,
party client organizer.
I would plan parties and
create parties for adults
for specific reasons,
either they wanted to learn
how to get high or they wanted
to get high with a girl,
and I would provide that,
I'd set it all up for them,
and I just got paid.
It was a party, I
planned a party for them,
that's all I did, you know?
And I wouldn't like going back to that,
but if you didn't get high,
I wouldn't mess with you.
All my clients have to get
high, I don't care what you do.
You have to indulge in
some kind of substance.
You have to indulge in something,
I don't care what it is.
Alcohol, whatever it is, I don't care.
You have to indulge in something,
or else I'm not messing with you.
That's just the way I feel,
that's just the way I am.
Personally, I get high. I'm an addict.
I don't fake the funk, I'm proud of it,
I don't deny it, I don't
regret it or nothing.
I don't regret anything I've
done in my life, anything.
I'm not ashamed of anything
I've done in my life.
I hold my head up high,
'cause that's what my
mama always taught me.
Everything happens to you for a reason.
Everything happens for a reason,
and I'm never gonna be ashamed or guilty
of anything I ever do in life
because that's what was meant to happen.
- Do you think your-
- I take that back.
I got one thing I regret, one
thing, one thing, one thing,
and that's getting high in
front of my kid, that's it.
- [Mark] Do you think
your childhood, the events
in your childhood, kind
of led you to this life?
- [Victoria] I think the-
- [Mark] You've been here a long time.
- [Victoria] Yeah, I've
been down here since '99.
It's what, 2019 now? Yeah.
Yeah, 20 years.
Wow.
- [Mark] The childhood you
had sounds like it was-
- Well I was 19 or 18
when I was down here,
so yeah, everyone thought I was a child,
everyone thought I was 13, 14 years old,
but I wasn't, I was 19.
I'm about one of the only girls down here
that was doing my thing right.
I had a lot of jealous
people, a lot of haters,
because for one, I got high,
and supposedly that drug
is a dirty, messed up drug.
It's a disgusting drug.
Well if that's the case,
then it wouldn't be
a rich man's high, 'cause
every rich man gets high
on cocaine or crack, I don't
care what you say, they do.
They get high on cocaine
or crack, one or the other.
It's a rich man's drug, that's what it is.
But you got to be rich to do it. (laughs)
I love getting high, I do, I love it.
It helps me bury my feelings,
it helps me numb my feelings.
I don't like feeling, and you can't have
feelings and emotions
on the streets anyways.
Feelings and emotions get
you fucked up and killed, so.
I kept my feelings
underneath for a long time,
but when my mom passed...
It's hard now, it's hard to keep a grip
on my feelings, even getting high.
I find myself
coming back to life more, now.
I guess the whole time
when I was living out here,
I basically, I died.
My son, my stepson, my
little brother who I adopted
when I was 18, when I
first went down here,
my mom had another child and
she asked me to come back
and take custody of him, so that way
the social services
wouldn't get him, right?
So I did, I took custody
of him at six months old.
As soon as I got off
the plane from Chicago,
my mom put that baby in my hands
and she was like, that's
yours, that's your baby.
You don't got no kids, that's your baby.
So that was my baby, you know?
His dad kidnapped him from me
and I lost it.
I literally felt something come
inside me and rip my gut out
when he crossed the border with him.
I didn't know where he
was for three years,
and that's what basically
got me to shut down
to where I let drugs take over.
'Cause...
Niggers do not want me to get sober
and bitches do not want me to get single,
'cause I will take over, seriously.
If I would stop being high, I
know I can do a lot of things
still without getting
high, but I'd rather choose
to get high and relearn how to discipline.
- [Mark] Let me ask you one more question
about the Frontier Hotel.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Is it true, all
the stories I've heard
about people-
- Yes.
- Falling off the top of the building?
- Yeah, not falling, pushed.
- Yeah, that's what I mean.
- Yeah, thrown, yeah, because
they almost did that to me.
- How many?
- They almost did that to me.
They tried, but I wasn't going down.
- [Mark] So when you lived there,
how many times did you see that happening?
- Well to be honest, the baby
and I found a dead body once.
But I'm not...
Hearing about it, more than once.
Seeing it and witnessing it, not at all.
I haven't seen or witnessed it.
I was gonna be one because I
almost jumped out the window
myself when the baby
got kidnapped from me.
I literally almost jumped out the window
and my friend caught me by my ankle
and I busted my chin on a
thing, I got a scar right here.
But yeah, I literally tried
to jump out the window
when that happened.
I didn't want to live.
I thought my baby was gone,
so who wants to live without
their child, you know?
Even though I didn't have
him, I felt, you know,
I felt everything that an
actual mother would feel
if they gave birth to their
child, you know what I mean?
Me and my brother were so close,
me and the baby were so close,
he was my kid, he was my son, you know?
He called me sissy mommy, you know?
He knew who his mother was, though.
He knew our mother was our mother,
and he knew I was his sister,
but he called me sissy mommy
because I was like his mommy.
I did everything for him.
I gave him his first birthday, everything.
I even dressed up like a damn
clown for his birthday, okay?
- Do you still talk to him?
- No.
He's in prison for murder.
Mark my words, I said, if
he lives with his father,
he's gonna either end up dead or in prison
by the time he's 18, sure enough.
His 17th birthday,
he stabbed his girlfriend
17 times to death.